okay i want to start today with how to
research a news story
that you read on the internet i often
talk about media literacy critical
thinking epistemology understanding why
we believe the things we believe
and part of this as news consumers is is
what i'm reading trustworthy can i
believe what i'm reading so i'm going to
do this in kind of order of depth and
time so like this is the order you could
do it in and you could stop at any time
this is this is going to be a lot of
work is is the truth uh and it's not
realistic that every news consumer is
going to do this level of research on
every single story but the typical thing
that happens is we have an article the
article says something
um and we need to figure out can can we
trust it um and this is to be very clear
not how you would do academic research i
know some people will say dave david
this is not how academics research
academic topics no no i'm just saying
this is something the average news
consumer can do
if you want to at least have a framework
for figuring out can i believe what i'm
reading so
i deliberately picked an article from
the website raw story to start with i'm
not criticizing raw story i'm just using
raw story because it's an article that
is emblematic of so much of what there
is on the internet which is it's
basically a rewrite it's not a primary
source
this is an article based on another
article okay so let's start here and
we'll go and you you could stop anywhere
but this is the order i'd suggest
you're presented with an article the
article is from raw story and it says
new york lieutenant governor brian
benjamin arrested on federal bribery
charges okay now you start reading
through the article and you will realize
oh this is not original reporting this
is a rewrite of an original article
in this case it's really easy to tell
because the first line is the new york
times reported that new york lieutenant
governor brian benjamin has surrendered
to federal authorities on bribery
charges now you can finish reading this
article if you want or you could go
right to the primary source so we go to
the primary source which is the new york
times article great
so
you can read this article this would be
the next thing to do lieutenant governor
benjamin resigns following campaign
finance indictment
brian benjamin new york second in
command to the governor was charged with
bribery okay so you read this article
great
now one thing that is useful to do in
assessing media bias would be well this
is a new york times article
what's the deal with the new york times
we all
sort of know the new york times but
imagine that it's a less well-known
primary source but the fir the next
thing that you would do is you would
google
the name of the media outlet and the
word bias
or the word
source watch if there's a source watch
page that can be useful
and you will find websites that will
assess the credibility of the source in
the case of the new york times there's
many
allsides.com will talk to you about the
new york times and it says the new york
times leans left
and it gives you information about how
that was determined and it tells you
different things about the new york
times the ad fontess media
page will have a page about the new york
times bias and reliability
source watch for some more prominent
media outlets
will tell you about what is the new york
times again new york times most of us
don't need to do this but you might come
across a source and you don't know if
it's credible so you would want to after
finding the primary source
learn a little bit about the media
outlet great
now sometimes
it's about the author of the article the
author themselves might be notable
in this case it's a group of authors
from the new york times william rashbaum
nicholas fandos and jeffrey mays
if bob woodward is the author
the author has a multi-decade history
and you can examine that to kind of
build your assessment of the of the
story
these are less well-known uh authors and
so just as an example
william rashbaum is not notable enough
to have his own wiki page but you can at
least look at the william rashbom page
on the new york times and it tells you
this is a senior writer metro staff he
does political and municipal corruption
so okay this is not like a culture
writer writing about political
corruption it's a political corruption
story and that's what this particular
journalist writes about
uh he used to cover federal courts in
brooklyn he was the newspaper's police
bureau chief great okay so we have a
bunch of information about william
rashbaum and he seems well suited based
on his experience to write about this
type of thing great okay so
we could stop here and we could say like
this is it the this is a it's an author
who knows about this topic
in a generally reliable media outlet
we're comfortable okay
now
you could go further
this is an article about
uh federal bribery
so you could actually say well let me
look at the underlying law and cornell
has a great website
where you can look up any law and
statute and you can say let me learn
what is in the bribery of public
officials and witnesses
federal statute because that's what this
entire story is based on great well i
might also want to know the history of
such charges who else has been charged
with federal bribery who's been
convicted is there a political nature to
these types of charges so there's a wiki
page called list of united states
officials the list of united states
state officials convicted of federal
corruption charges which includes
bribery now you might say well but david
wikipedia is not a good source
wikipedia is a great aggregation when
there are citations because you can
start looking through this list and you
see all these different people governor
rod blagojevich and many others and
there's citations for all of these you
can actually look at notes and if you
say oh okay well what was the deal with
rod blagojevich's conviction
so it's actually very very useful for
that and then also you know it could be
useful again diving deeper to look at
information about the person that the
article is about this entire story is
about the lieutenant governor brian
benjamin so you might start with their
wiki page and again you're not using
wiki so much as a source you're using it
as a kind of clearinghouse for citations
and you could learn about brian
benjamin's history does he have a
history of legal trouble
uh
on and on okay so so you would go from
there you could find kind of key
information about the person in their
bio that's not in the article so this is
like
the minimum to really more deeply start
understanding a topic and knowing
whether remember we started with a
rewrite on raw story
and compare what you would know just
reading the raw story article versus
actually doing this work now this is
just a framework
imagine it's a science story well that's
arguably more complex imagine that we're
looking at an article about
um
anti-nuclear activists
uh
are warning about building new nuclear
well okay that's a lot so is it the
original source or not we would want to
go to the primary source but nuclear
power is a major academic topic so we
might even go to scholar.google.com
and search for nuclear power nuclear
safety differences between 40-year-old
nuclear power and modern nuclear power
okay so so it takes work
and understandably
most people don't have time to do this
level of investigation
for every news story you get but it
should at least let you know that
reading a piece on raw story is not
going to leave you informed in a way
that i would like to be
if i'm going to be talking about a topic
keep in mind when the anti-vaxxers say
i've done my research
think about what research they may have
done and you can actually use this
framework to inquire and probe whether
they've really actually done their
research so hopefully this is useful
let me know maybe at some point i'll do
another example with you know i
deliberately picked a pretty cut and dry
story which is just like a guy got
arrested and here's here's why
um
to show the depth you can go in even for
that if this is useful i'm glad to glad
to do it again with other topics
at this point
a fox news is a tool
for russian propaganda now i'm not
asserting any kind of collusion
i'm not saying russian uh
officials are feeding talking points to
fox news i'm not saying any of that but
what i am saying is fox news's coverage
of the russian invasion of ukraine is
really useful from the standpoint of
propaganda value to russian state
television i've previously told you
about this memo this was about from
about a month ago exactly a month ago in
fact a kremlin memo
was sent to russian media
saying it's essential to feature tucker
carlson's commentaries in in terms of
their
uh coverage of the russian invasion of
ukraine
and particularly early on
tucker's coverage was very very pleasant
for russian propaganda purposes so we
already talked about that previously
that's that leaked memo
we also uh
know
that russian state television has
referred to former democratic
congresswoman tulsi gabbard as our
friend
on the basis of her interviews with yes
also
with tucker carlson
and we now also have another example of
this
wherein um
russian media
has aired
a clip from fox about so-called growing
concern over far-left lunacy in schools
which includes trans rights clay travis
was the guest a right-wing media
personality as he's often referred to
and that was also useful remember that
in the midst of the russian invasion of
ukraine russian state media continues to
be obsessed with a very similar kind of
anti-woke so-called anti-woke ideology
that is very much in line with vladimir
putin's cultural
preferences cultural positions and
there's a lot of great material from fox
news when it comes to that so it's
always really important when we look at
these things to understand that
the term useful idiot is often really
useful and i know it sounds like a
pejorative but it's it's a it's a term a
useful idiot is someone who is being
used by others for their own gain
without even realizing it so very often
you know back in the trump-russia
investigation days
there were some
i guess
who were setting their standard as
is there going to be video of trump
colluding with vladimir putin and and
putin telling trump what he needs him to
do and whatever and and as i and many
others said
that's never going to happen that's not
how these things work we're not talking
about that what we're talking about is
more of a useful idiot relationship
where trump wouldn't even realize
that he is furthering the goals of
russia which is making the u.s look like
a joke which it was when trump was
president uh making our democracy appear
unstable by fomenting the idea that what
would it did the winner really win this
type of thing and similarly it's not
that russia's giving tucker carlson
talking points it's sort of similar to i
i hate to say this because i had friends
uh who who worked for rt television but
a lot of rt people used to all when rt
was still on the air in the us they
would say they hired me
they never told me what i had to say
they never edited my script they never i
do whatever i want here
you were hired
either because what you are already
planning to say is useful to russian
state media or
because your presence by virtue of your
identity is useful even if you're not
towing the party line it's sort of like
you could say when shep smith was on fox
news and we would say he's he's the lone
voice of reason um
and it was the po the whole point was it
allowed fox to say we're fair and
balanced we have all sorts of different
views here nobody was telling shep what
to say but he was on for one hour
and then the rest and then they could
say well you know we're fair and
balanced we have all sorts of views so
understand when we say useful idiot
it the term idiot is pejorative but
useful idiot in total
describes someone who is
unknowingly being used by others to
further their agenda and that's exactly
what we're seeing on fox news uh next
tuesday 6 pm eastern april 19th we'll be
doing the next david pakman show viewer
town hall i hope you'll join me
everybody's welcome to call in and it'll
be streaming live on our second youtube
channel that's youtube.com
pacmanlive we'll take a very quick break
and be right back
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
the david pakman show is a community
grassroots supported program we're
supported by our audience and the best
ways through our membership program at
joinpacman.com you can sign up and get
yourself a membership you can also gift
a membership we have nearly 700 people
who have asked for free memberships
people who want one but can't afford one
you can ask for a free membership at
davidpakman.com free membership you can
give a membership by signing up at
joinpacman.com
and checking the box that says this is a
gift when you go through the sign up
process of course all of our members get
the daily bonus show an extra show
that we do
every day for our subscribers i want to
talk a little bit about former vice
president mike pence it's not clear to
me whether mike pence has presidential
ambitions uh mike pence yesterday
however gave a speech at the university
of virginia and it's actually notable
and painful
how terrible and uninspiring a speaker
mike pence is we're going to look at a
couple of clips now as as many of you of
course no doubt know if you've been
following american politics for
certainly the last five years if not the
last 10 or 15.
this sort of archetypal
prototypical
uh idea of the alpha male is a really
big deal in right-wing politics in
republican politics in the united states
and mike pence in the context of
appearing to or trying to make joe biden
look weak in relation to vladimir putin
made the case that
he went put toe to toe with putin
and he told putin things that he didn't
want to hear
and it's all just so obviously bogus
take a look at this
i've also met vladimir putin yeah i
stood toe-to-toe with him and i've told
him things he didn't want to hear oh
let me tell all of you
putin only understands strength
and america must meet this moment with
american strength
now there's a couple different things
here
first of all
is he saying he wants a war because if
you look at what the biden
administration has done so far in
ukraine
it's almost everything short of boots on
the ground i mean okay the us hasn't
that we know
carried out drone strikes in russia
but the u.s has provided drones to
ukraine so
short of boots on the ground it's
the us has done almost everything that
can be done there's not a no-fly zone
which in theory if there was the us
could be involved in enforcing which is
basically world war three if i as i've
explained to you before
but
this is the guy who was vice president
to trump who said i'm gonna keep us out
of wars and he seems to be saying by not
going fully to war
joe biden is not showing strength or
strength as mike pence says so that's
one piece of this
the other part of this is
i looked at the video
of when mike pence met vladimir putin
and we're going to play it here without
audio the it's just background noise is
the audio from when they met
and
it's not really a domineering mike pence
when you look at this
pence looks extraordinarily tense
and putin seems to be the guy kind of
controlling the conversation if you
watch it it's a full two minutes you see
pence sort of saying okay and nodding
it's putin whose agenda is dominating
it's putin who's setting the ground
rules and the stakes here
it didn't really seem like mike pence
was the big alpha when they actually met
um so
the idea that pence is the prototypical
strong alpha male is just an absolute
and and total joke it really seemed like
it was putin in control there so nothing
more pathetic than pence trying to be
the epitome of what he thinks his
supporters need to see
as the definition of of manly strength
now just a as a as another note here
the degree to which pence is just a
terrible speaker was unavoidably obvious
during the speech at the university of
virginia yesterday check out this segue
mike pence saying that our hearts are
broken because of the terrible attack
that took place in the new york city
subway yesterday which we'll talk about
later on today
he says you know our prayers are just
with those there
and then he goes directly into talking
about getting to drive a car now that
he's no longer vp and it's a terrible
insensitive segue and he flubs the line
like just everything going wrong this
guy is such a terrible speaker
our hearts broke this morning with the
headline of the terrible violence that
took place on the subway of new york and
our prayers our prayers are with the
injured and the victims and their
families
you know one of the advantages of being
vice president is i get to drive my own
car again
one of the disadvantages is i get to pay
for my own gas
wow what what a deeply in spot just an
electric speaker and really the empathy
is just so sincere
guys this guy is horrible this this guy
he
he really just knows how to soothe
people in difficult situ it's one of the
most uninspiring speakers in the modern
republican party you you feel nothing
other than revulsion creepy revulsion
when he speaks and
i guess what he meant to say is
now that i'm no longer vice president
i can drive my own car but instead he
says one of the great things about being
vice president
it's just all a mess now the political
question is
does he have political ambitions
presidential ambitions and do
republicans have any interest in mike
pence being the republican nominee right
now the answer seems no if you go to
predict.org which is these are these are
betting markets you can bet on just
about any political question who will
win the 2024 republican presidential
nomination it's still trump in the lead
over ron desantis although ron desantis
is really closing in on trump and we'll
talk about that later but mike pence
down in fourth place five cents out of
every dollar being bet
is going to mike pence will be the
republican nominee in 2024 so we will
watch it pence is an absolutely horrible
person a terrible speaker but
i never after trump in 2016 you're not
going to hear me say
x will never be
the republican nominee it could be
anybody it could be ted nugent for all i
know
one thing is you don't want to overstate
the common sense and intelligence of the
republican electorate and so i'm not
going to uh there's a very interesting
segment from msnbc that i want to look
at with you where a republican
strategist went on and said
trump's influence trump's power in the
republican party is rapidly diminishing
as evidenced by his smaller and smaller
rally crowds you thought i was going to
say some trump's smaller and smaller
something else no i'm talking about his
rally crowds of course this is a really
interesting segment and there's actually
a very interesting political question
here um donald trump has long equated
crowd size with success even bragging
about the size of the january 6 riot mob
republican strategist susan del percio
said trump is now falling short by that
measure as his rally crowds decrease in
size now one important thing is you
might say but david trump hasn't
conceded that his rally crowds are
diminishing in size i know we covered a
recent trump rally
and trump said there were 87 000 people
in the audience there were five to seven
thousand people in the audience trump
recently did an event where you can
publicly look up the capacity of the
venue it was 5500 and trump said there
were tens of thousands of people there
trump's not telling you the truth about
the crowd size but there's a good
question here given that the crowds have
been diminishing is that actually
evidence that trump's influence in the
party is diminishing let's listen to
susan del percio on msnbc i want to ask
you about congressman madison cawthord
how do you interpret that warm welcome
he got is he the future of the gop
absolutely not he is the future of
donald trump and his shrinking base and
that's what you saw there a very
shrinking base i'm not saying that the
republican party is going to come out of
donald trump two for even six years but
even this congress member is being
shunned by members of his own party
donald trump yes he can bring out those
people but those crowds are getting
smaller
and people aren't buying into it mostly
because democrat and republicans excuse
me want to move on they don't want to
talk about the big lie the people of
this country don't want to hear about it
anymore they're done with donald trump
and his lies
except for a small group that we see
there i don't know that that's true
i don't know that that's true
it is clear
that trump's power may be diminishing
and the 2022 midterms are going to be a
big factor in helping us figure that out
it's not really clear to me that by any
significant margin trump's power in the
republican party is diminishing and i
think it's really important to remember
the 2020 election
if you looked at the democratic primary
before joe biden won it
and you just said let me pick some ways
to determine enthusiasm
you would have seen that joe biden
wasn't having big rally crowds now i
don't know that he was trying because of
the pandemic and things that were going
on at the time but if you took a look at
the rally crowds and then you looked on
reddit and twitter you would have said
oh wow bernie's going to run away with
this thing biden has no chance and it
wasn't reflective of what was going on
with the average democratic voter in so
many different states around the country
and people get mad at me when i say this
i'm not telling you this because it was
the way i would have liked it to be i'm
telling you this because it was the way
it was
joe biden's support was dramatically
understated and bernie support was
dramatically overstated similarly
trump had far bigger crowds than biden
throughout the throughout the campaign a
lot of it was biden wasn't trying to do
big events because of the pandemic but
if you go by rally crowd i think you're
going to end up confused there are lots
of people who just don't see politicians
as cult leaders essentially
they don't really care about going to a
rally i don't care about political
rallies you know
i'm not looking to put myself in
situations where i've got to line up for
four hours outside
uh and then use these feted sani cans
for hours while i'm waiting for i i'll
just watch it at home i don't need to go
and so i don't really know that we can
make too much of the rally crowds a few
things we can look at are polls if you
look at recent republican primary polls
from the last couple of months you see
that in nevada donald trump is still
easily winning if you these are 2024
polls in massachusetts among republicans
donald trump is easily winning in
minnesota trump is winning uh actually
no i'm sorry in minnesota trump is not
winning uh but in most states trump is
either basically tied for first or
easily in first place so i just don't
think we have the evidence at this point
that trump's power in the party is
diminishing again looking at the
predict.org numbers these are the
betting numbers trump is still
i don't want to say running away with it
but
39 cents of every dollar being bet are
trump will be the nominee
29 cents are going to desantis so that
is close that is close compared to what
it was but trump is still in the lead my
hope is that it's an extraordinarily
ugly divisive and destructive 2024
primary but to even get to that we've
got to get past the midterms
we'll have all of these stories on our
instagram you can find us there
at david pakman show
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show let's talk a little
bit about cnn's new streaming service
cnn plus now i know some of you will say
david what are you talking about cnn
plus i haven't even i haven't even heard
of that uh that's exactly the problem i
don't i don't blame you if you haven't
heard of it i've only heard of it
because i've had conversations about it
with with my agent about do we want to
make a pitch to cnn plus and i'm going
to get back to that in a second um if
you did not know cnn plus launched it's
part of why it's already downsizing and
this makes me think even more strongly
that the future of media is going to be
in
sort of
narrow casting independent media uh
there is a great report there's a couple
of reports actually that are interesting
a cnbc reporting cnn plus struggles to
lure viewers in its early days drawing
fewer than 10 000 daily users now for
people who don't understand
disastrous these numbers are
understand that they are now two weeks
into their existence cnn plus
and they are seeing fewer than 10 000
people a day using the the streaming
service into which cnn has poured
millions and millions and millions there
are i don't know for sure
but there are probably individual cnn
plus shows
whose budget is multiple times that of
the david pakman show just one of their
shows they're getting 10 000 total
viewers a day
we are on 150 radio and television
stations
on satellite television
we get a million youtube views per day
we get 50 000 podcast downloads
per day per day per episode i guess
better said
um
and they're getting 10 000 viewers on
this entire thing
each day
and as cnbc reports the paltry audience
casts doubt on the future of the
application
following the uh following the recent um
completed combination of discovery and
warner media into warner brothers
discovery
uh warner brothers discovery ceo david
saslov hasn't commented publicly on cnn
plus his long-term future he told cnbc
in february he'd need to see how it
performs before making any other
decisions
people spoke with cnbc on the condition
of anonymity cnn plus launched on march
29
it costs 5.99 a month
those are our prices
those are that's that's amazing those
are our exact prices we charge six bucks
a month for membership and 60 a year
annually it only became available on
roku it's still not on android tv so i
guess as it grows then it might
you know i don't know i guess maybe
maybe it'll do better
um
and they're already doing some
downsizing there's also an axios report
big cuts coming for cnn plus after a
slow start investment in projections for
cnn plus are expected to be cut
dramatically in response to a low
adoption rate
uh hundreds of millions of dollars
hundreds of millions are expected to be
cut from the original investment total
of a billion to date 300 million dollars
has been spent i i just to put this in
context if we got a cash infusion
um
of five million dollars
it's insane what we would be able to do
with our show
if you get five million dollars for a
show like ours that has an
established loyal audience and we have
distribution methods and all these
things
we just pour the money into youtube ads
facebook ads and twitter ads make it so
on youtube our videos show up as
pre-roll ads whenever you go to cnn or
daily wire
we take proven content and we just dump
money into putting it in front of people
the return on investment would be crazy
it would be crazy and there that that's
if we got five million in cash infusion
300 million dollars has been spent
for 10 000 viewers a day okay so that's
enough
i'm not ragging on them but what i'm
pointing to here
is
we have a very drastically different
media landscape
and in times past
the legacy power of cnn
or the legacy power of fox news or or
whatever
would guarantee success when you go oh
well let's also do streaming let's go
from legacy media to streaming
now because of the increased ubiquity of
the internet
the increased ability of the consumer to
say i i don't need cnn packaging 10
shows for me i'll pick my 10 shows and
i'll watch david pakman and then i'll
watch you know anthony magna bosco
street epistemology and i'll listen to
steven novella's podcast and then i'll
go to no mickey's show where you but you
can build it yourself and it's really no
less convenient with all of the tools
that are around so people just don't
seem to care about that curation
that was so powerful in legacy media you
can curate yourself
um
what else did i want to say about this
oh i've had i've had conversations
recently with my agent about
uh we've had inquiries from other
streaming networks i'm not going to name
them because it just doesn't doesn't
seem appropriate where they've said
would you guys want to submit a proposal
and i would go back and forth with with
my agent and you know we would realize
they want an original proposal so
basically what it would mean is i would
do this show every day but then they
would want me doing another show only
for them and when we looked at the money
involved and we looked at the five
layers of management and oversight and
editors i don't want five bosses telling
me what to do to double my work every
single day so we've we've passed on even
making some of these proposals um and it
seems that as unappealing as it was to
us as content creators
at least cnn plus is appearing to be
pretty unappealing uh to consumers as
well so i think that this bodes well i
have no problem with cnn plus i just
think this bodes well for independent
media that's really what i think it
means where people are deciding for
themselves i'll curate
i don't need 24 hours of cnn plus let me
know your thoughts let me know whether
you even pay attention to these types of
networks
i want to
play a couple of clips for you
of a man
appearing thrilled
that
nancy pelosi has covered
this is this is really disgusting stuff
back during the late period the late era
the late stages of the trump
administration
you had people like don jr and others
saying democrats are taking pleasure
in people getting coveted and dying of
covet and of course it wasn't true
there were it just wasn't true it wasn't
happening it wasn't happening
but i'm going to play a clip for you now
of trump speaking somewhere or who even
knows
where he really seems to be taking
pleasure in playing very coy with nancy
pelosi testing positive for covid nancy
pelosi is 82 years old hopefully she's
well protected from the vaccine i've not
seen an update as to how she's doing
over the last 48 hours but hopefully
she's improving
um and here's trump kind of goading the
crowd with we want her to get well right
right and you can tell exactly what he's
doing here
[Applause]
by the way
lock her up
again the people that say they're for
law and order say skip due process don't
charge her don't try her
she's not even being investigated for
anything just lock her up that's not law
and order guys lock her up
[Applause]
okay now we're having trouble with the
video let's see if we can get the video
back here uh okay
uh technical issues plaguing us today
okay let's get back to it here
[Applause]
so trump says we want her to get well
right everybody want her to get well and
the crowd says now
and some others haven't
uh just happened
but you know uh nancy pelosi is in
charge of capital security does anybody
know that
so so uh trump really seems shaken up
there by uh by by nancy pelosi
uh
having coronavirus and then here's just
one other really weird clip from this
event i think you're probably more aware
of what's called the china virus
they released the china virus so after
years after years
of
no evidence that china released anything
and guys if they did i want to know
investigate
i've never been one of these people that
says it's racist to ask the question
if you get the if the first cases are in
country a
you look at country a and say well what
happened there but there's no evidence
that china released anything but it
doesn't matter trump keeps alluding to
that
the word from by the way where the hell
did that word come from
they had all sorts of things the only
thing that you want to mention was the
name china okay so continuing
uh just everything everything bizarre
about this event and you know it we
continue as i've said before the level
of projection from these folks is wild
they say look at this the other side is
doing that they're probably doing it
themselves hillary with uh sensitive
information
private email servers
records keeping
they're going to rob they're going to
try to steal the election well they they
tried to steal the election even though
uh trump lost
uh and with all we they want people to
die of covid you guys are the guys who
seem to laugh
whenever a democrat gets it whenever a
prominent democrat gets it these are
these are disgusting people
and um they are
everything that they accuse the left of
doing they actually are themselves it's
vile to see
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick talk
i think you'll get a kick out of this
maria bartiromo on fox news and fox
business has become one of the most
weaponized brown nosers for everything
trump and everything andy biden she used
to be a pretty serious financial
journalist when i was growing up and
started following the stock market she
was reporting from the floor of the new
york stock exchange and doing really
good interviews of fortune 500 ceos and
she has become nothing but
a trump brown noser and a right-wing
extremist at least as far as her on
on-screen presentation
and she was interviewing house minority
leader kevin mccarthy
no moderate centrist by any stretch of
the imagination i mean mccarthy is a
right-wing loon and she brings up
impeaching biden like oh would you
definitely impeach biden if you take
control of the house
and mccarthy doesn't go for it
as much as mccarthy would love to
impeach biden if he thought he could get
away with it and if he thought that it
would be good politically
even mccarthy seems to be playing a
little bit of a whoa whoa whoa let's
slow down for a second here maria this
is fascinating to see let's take a look
i spoke with one of your colleagues
on friday on fox business greg murphy
and he told me that all of the things
that he is seeing from president biden
are impeachable but the congress is
worried about it what what
what things are those i mean this is
just out of this world nuttery teaching
him because they're not so confident
about his number two here's greg murphy
i want to get your reaction to this
watch by the way
imagine thinking hey you know what we
could impeach and remove biden but then
kamala becomes the president and that's
not good so we're not going to imp what
what are you talking about
i think there's going to be plenty of
foot there's plenty if you look at
afghanistan you look at the border
crisis you look at so many of these
different things the sad thing is maria
look at who's number two
look at who's number two i think number
two and think about that impeach biden
for getting out of afghanistan
which trump was scheduled to do if he
had won and remained president why why
would you impeach him impeach biden
because of the situation at the border
which is essentially unchanged from when
trump was president what are these
people talking about and the viewers
don't know they just have no idea
they're like oh yeah yeah it sounds
right two is worse than number one so
this is the predict predicament that
we're in but these offenses that this
president has done against the heart and
soul of this country against law and
order i think stands our grounds for
impeachable offenses
congressman what about that will you
move to impeach president biden
look one thing we learned that the
democrats did is they they used
impeachment for political reason we
believe in the rule of law we're not
going to pick and choose just because
somebody has power we're going to uphold
the law at any time if someone breaks
the law and the ramification comes
impeachment we would move towards that
but we're not going to use it for
political purposes our focus is going to
be securing our border making us energy
independent
bringing these prices down making our
schools safe in our streets again and
holding this administration accountable
and we will take the facts to wherever
the facts go because america has been
through too much anyway so i don't
believe a word he's saying and what i
mean by that is
mccarthy would be right there impeaching
biden for sure if he thought it would
help him politically but right now he
knows it's too crazy crazy for the
minority leader of the house to just
come out and say our plan is to impeach
joe biden now as a counterpoint marjorie
taylor greene is saying that and the
things she's saying are way crazier than
the things even maria bartoromo is
saying as crazy as impeaching biden for
getting out of afghanistan would be
listen to what marjorie taylor green has
planned if republicans take control of
the house
congressional record that we can now
expose on that laptop
here's what we do after that
right
we need to impeach kamala harris
[Applause]
why
why can't they get kamala harris's name
correct
at this point
at in all on all honesty
do you think they're doing it on purpose
that they it's a subtle dig
i mean you know like for example you
know i say tulsi gabbard and i admit
it's a completely juvenile dig i think
she's a completely unserious person
and the idea that i can't even be
bothered to to learn her name i find it
funny uh when it comes to kamala do you
think they're doing it on purpose do you
think they genuinely can't learn kamala
harris's name like what do you what do
you think is behind it
because you can't encourage and promote
raise money for criminal rioters and
expect to serve the interest of the
people the great people in the united
states that is that is a conflict of
interest she is not kidding
there is a group within the republican
party
and it may be the mainstream of the
republican party it remains to be seen
in the sense of
we'll see who gets behind it if and when
they take control of the house there is
a group that is determined to impeach
joe biden how do we know well some of
them have already written up articles of
impeachment they don't go anywhere
because republicans don't control the
house but lauren beaubert
has written up articles of impeachment
marjorie taylor green has for now people
like kevin mccarthy are just holding
short they're saying wow
we'll impeach if that's what should
happen but he's not committing to an
impeachment
um
they're going to do it and this is yet
another reason why if republicans do
take control of the house or imagine if
they take control of both the house and
senate in november
uh it is going to be
obstruction city biden will get nothing
else done and
there may be an impeachment trial
to serve as a distraction during the
second two years the the third and
fourth years the second half
of joe biden's first term as president
uh they're going to do it when they're
they're telling us they're going to do
it and i believe that they're going to
do it and it's going to be a nightmare
we have been increasingly concerned with
what's going on with abortion rights in
the united states and the message that i
had
when um
donald trump became president
and started selecting people to the
supreme court was
they're not giving up they're going to
try they're going to do everything they
can to make abortion illegal
and they're going to do it by appealing
cases to the supreme court and they
didn't
and we are now waiting to see what the
supreme court decides but in the
meantime states aren't wasting any time
oklahoma republicans have passed the law
forcing a woman
to have her rapists baby
it is a near total ban on abortion with
no exceptions for rape or incest
this isn't going to stop they're going
to keep doing it
um
governor kevin's tit who's the governor
of oklahoma
says as governor i represent all four
million oklahomans and they
overwhelmingly support protecting life
we want oklahoma to be the most pro-life
state in the country we want to outlaw
abortion in the state of oklahoma
they're not kidding around
the bill also says
anyone found guilty of an abortion think
about the language guilt if you're found
guilty of an abortion
you can get up to ten years in jail
and a hundred thousand dollar fine
there are cases where convicted rapists
don't get ten years in jail
and a hundred thousand dollar fine some
get only a few months jail time
and uh oklahoma governor
stitt
signed the legislation and it nearly
bans all abortions in oklahoma the only
exception left the only carved out
exception left
is to save the life of a pregnant woman
in a medical emergency and of course who
gets to decide
what such a medical emergency is
now one of the
odd things about this new law
is that oklahoma already has a law on
the books banning all abortions except
when necessary to preserve the life of
the pregnant person
the old law only has a five-year prison
sentence the new law ups the maximum to
ten years and a hundred thousand dollars
so
it's not even we have no law and we are
anti-abortion so let's pass a law no no
no no it's we already have a law we just
don't think the punishment is strict
enough so let's pass another law it's
become a race to the bottom with these
republican culture wars and we could all
be living i mean modern technology and
medicine and innovation
would allow us to be living in an age
uh
sort of sort of led by
science and enlightenment
but we are fighting a group of people
that is determined
to have
a country based on extreme christian
fundamentalism and many of these
republicans when you talk to them
their anti-abortion stance is based on a
religious belief it's not a
science-based belief it's a religious
belief now strictly speaking we have
separation of church and state
formally
you're not supposed to be able to
justify a law
with religious doctrine in other words
it can't be written in the law that
because of what the bible says abortion
is illegal
but all of these republicans are using
the bible to justify their votes for
sure i'm not saying there's any way to
prevent that i mean you get into some
really dicey first amendment issues
but understand that we have plenty of
law in this country that is based on
the religious beliefs of the elected
officials and they're entitled to those
beliefs for sure
but strictly speaking
officially those beliefs can't be the
state's justification for a law
uh and and again i'm not saying that
the free exercise of religion should be
suppressed but religion is being used at
the individual level to get all of this
stuff done now there's an important
upcoming event
it is very plausible i don't know that i
want to call it likely i want to
maintain maintain some optimism but it
is possible
that roe v wade is in its final days
because we are expecting a decision in
late june from the supreme court
last december the supreme court heard
arguments in dobbs v jacobson
uh women's health sorry dobbs v jackson
women's health organization this is a
mississippi case
and it's asking the court to overturn
roe v wade and there are six justices
currently on the court
who are at least open to overturning roe
v wade some of them are eager to do so
22 states already have abortion bans on
the books and so if roe v wade is
effectively overturned by the
forthcoming supreme court decision those
22 states
already have laws that basically ban all
abortions and most of those would take
effect immediately if roe v wade is uh
is overturned a fascinating but grim
reality is that some of those abortion
bans in certain states
pre-date roe v wade they are
really archaic
and those are the anti-abortion laws
that that would immediately be in play
if roe v wade is overturned in late june
by the supreme court so the framework is
already there
and we could be seeing the united states
rapidly accelerate to a sort of sci-fi
dystopian situation with a resurgence of
sort of back alley slash underground
abortion clinics
people leaving states in order to get
the services they need elsewhere
you know i often say we do we don't want
to point to a slippery slope when
there's unlikely to actually be one we
don't want to unnecessarily fear monger
that's a tool of the reactionary right
this is a very real possibility that we
are now facing and there wisconsin's law
makes abortion a felony punishable
by up to six years in prison
that law is over a hundred years old and
it's not likely to be repealed meaning
if roe v wade is overturned
that's the wisconsin law that goes into
place it's not been relevant because of
roe v wade
scary times ahead
very very scary times ahead we have a
voicemail number and that number is 2192
david p
i don't like the voicemail i'm about to
play for you
i think the caller is calling me racist
uh a couple days ago i said oprah
bears some responsibility for unleashing
dr oz mehmet oz onto the world
and this caller i think is saying i'm
racist for saying that
hello
i'm so confused with myself because i
can't believe i'm calling
but something you said really annoyed me
and to be honest i normally just ignore
these asides by
certain demographics
demographics uh-oh it sounds like
because i appear to be white
i said the wrong thing
because if they don't have black friends
or anything like maybe they just don't
get it well meaning as they might be
they might just say
anyway i was really surprised to hear
you
um
use the
oprah thing and say the real question is
why oprah unleashed mermaid oz into the
world blah blah blah
and i realized you said you were joking
a lot of people say that and then say
they're joking
it's not a joke um
oprah is not responsible for anything to
do with these people and their views on
all of this
she had a production company i believe
and um hired people based on shows
that could make money nobody blames mark
burnett for
donald trump actually a lot of people do
a lot of people do a lot of people say
if mark burnett had never given trump
the apprentice
trump never would have become president
so that's wrong but listen here's the
thing guys oprah being black has nothing
to do with why i said she's responsible
for unleashing mem at oz
way before years before mehmet oz got
the dr oz show produced by oprah
oprah invited dr oz onto her show more
than 60 times okay so
it this has nothing to do with race
and of course if oprah invites someone
60 times and they have no popular appeal
they're not going to all of a sudden be
a viable senate candidate but oprah as
as she has launched the careers of many
people i mean listen oprah's responsible
for dr phil i would argue who by the way
is not a psychologist
um uh
it
it's it has nothing to do with race
oprah's responsible for many people
being well known mehmet oz is one of
them dr phil mcgraw is another one of
them and that's it
it's i this is this is the exact you
know i say this stuff is not really
common on the left but sometimes you see
it
this is the stuff that just
i it's race related that i said
oprah's responsible for mehmet oz give
me a break guys give me a break it's not
uh this ain't it as the kids these days
like to say we have a great bonus show
for you today producer pat will be
making his triumphant return to the
bonus show after a few days off we are
going to talk about the horrible
shooting in the new york subway we'll
tell you what is now known
shanghai china residents
who are screaming from their windows
during lockdown are getting visits from
drones warning them about their behavior
and we will also talk about new
allegations that elon musk by delaying
the announcement of the stake he
purchased in twitter
saved a bundle on his taxes all of those
stories and more will be addressed in a
serious manner today on the bonus show
you can get instant access to the bonus
show by signing up at joinedpakman.com
don't miss it
and if you already have a membership you
can gift a membership gift a membership
at
joinpackman.com
lastly tuesday april 19th at 6 p.m we'll
be doing the next david pakman show
viewer town hall
everybody's welcome to call in we'll be
streaming the town hall live on our
second youtube channel that's the pacman
live youtube channel hope to see you
there and remember that everybody's
welcome to call in but our website
members will get a priority line to call
in
uh sign up at jointpakman.com
you